In this lesson, we'll talk about the web
and how web caches can improve web performance.
We will study, in particular, the hyper-text transfer
protocol, or HTTP, which is an application layer
protocol to transfer web content. It's the protocol
that your web browser uses to request web
pages, and it's also the protocol that the
responses, or the web pages. Or the objects
that are returned as part of a webpage are returned to your browser. Your web
browser makes requests for webpages, and the pages and the objects in the page
come back as responses. HTTP is typically layered on
top of a byte stream protocol, which is almost always TCP. The client
sends a request to a server, asking for web content and the
server responds with the content often encoded in text. The
server maintains no information about past client requests. Thus
we say the server is stateless. Let's take a
quick look into the format of HTTP requests, and responses.